pas
[Musique]
dans le cadre de la semaine européenne
du développement durable le conseil
départemental et edf mettent en place un
important programme d'actions de
sensibilisation à destination des
collégiens
ce vendredi 31 mai c'est au collège
emile hugot de la bretagne qui a été
lancée la première étape de cette action
les collégiens se sont vus remettre un
coffret de six lampes led
l'objectif prendre conscience de
l'importance d'une consommation
vertueuse pour préserver notre
environnement et participer à la
transition énergétique de la réunion
les collégiens qui sont jeunes ce sont
les citoyens de demain et dans toutes
les opérations de développement durable
que nous menons département en vocation
à sensibiliser les jeunes
notre jeunesse et surtout les collégiens
à faire des petites actions chacun dans
son coin pour faire des économies
d'énergie
c'est donc une sensibilisation à
l'écocitoyenneté que nous menons et cet
éco citoyenneté passe naturellement par
nos jeunes par nos collégiens agir sur
les équipements et agir sur les
comportements
c'est à dire que l'objectif c'est de
sensibiliser les jeunes collégiens à la
maîtrise de la demande d'énergie à la
réduction de
de la consommation d'électricité en
s'équipant mieux sensibilisation sur ce
nouveau matériel les ampoules led et
puis en apprenant à bien les utiliser
pour simplement adopter les éco gestes
efficaces
on allume une lumière uniquement quand
on a besoin et on essaye d'avoir une
ampoule la moins énergivore possible et
ça ça passe par un travail de
sensibilisation des plus jeunes
le changement de ces lampes led
permettra à chaque famille de réaliser
jusqu'à 20 euros d'économies sur sa
facture annuelle sur une baisse de
consommation d'énergie de 4% et aux
jeunes de devenir des acteurs de la
consommation d'énergie dans leurs foyers
bah c'est important déjà parce qu'ils
sont venus avait quand même des
explications assez précise
donc c'est vrai que ça met un peu des
démos on va dire sur sur mes pensées si
parfois et c'est vrai que comme je l'aï
dit tout à l'heure j'en ai parlé un peu
on est les futurs acteurs de demain et
donc c'est important que nous en tant
qu'ambassadeur aidant plus en parler
dans le collège pour les élèves qui sont
pas présents et aux 109 familles aussi
je vais l'installer directement passer
des ampoules led à basse consommation où
on va les utiliser directement passe
pour réduire la consommation d'énergie
et enlever les neiges
alors les ampoules des établissements
des collèges est prévu l'intégralité
au fur et à mesure
le vieillissement toutes les ampoules
seront changés et ce qu'on passait en
anglais au collège emile hugot qui
compte 4 185 élèves se sont de 1910
l'emplette qui ont été distribués à
partir de lundi 3 juin commencera la
distribution dans l'ensemble des
collèges de lui
au total 360 millions seront remises
[Musique]